[Music]
the origin of birds has been a classical
challenge in evolutionary biology
traditionally for most of the 20th
century birds were so different from
other vertebrates that they were really
considered to be a group apart from
other vertebrates birds and animals
right and scientifically what that came
to mean is that birds were a kind of
reptile with no particular relation to
any specific reptiles however in the
late 20th century scientists who were
interested in explicitly reconstructing
the tree of life that is the genealogy
of species building the tree of life
discovered that birds evolved from a
group of theropod dinosaurs those are
the the big bipedal meat-eaters like
Velociraptor and t-rex etc right this
opinion was extremely controversial at
the time and led to a protracted debate
for decades between the the the theropod
origin or the dinosaur origin of birds
and what came to be known as the Dino
deniers folks that rejected the dinosaur
origin of birds but were unable to
explicitly articulate an alternative
hypothesis for the origin of birds right
this is really a case study of how
scientific revolutions happen right
because early on this seemed like a
crackpot theory but over basically about
two decades three decades the evidence
started to pile up until finally it was
irrefutable of course the the final and
most dramatic evidence of this were the
origin of feathers and when people found
feathers on theropod dinosaurs like
close relatives of velociraptor the guy
who chased the kids around in the
kitchen
hid in Jurassic Park then people really
realize Wow birds are dinosaurs and in
this sense they didn't just come from
dinosaurs they are dinosaurs living
amongst us 10,000 species are found on
all continents around the world so the
answer to how scientific revolutions
happen is always do good science and and
and since science is a self-repairing
process that is it improves itself with
the scrutiny and new evidence that
progress has really led to knowledge in
this case the pattern of progress in
modern sizes is incontrovertible however
one of the downsides of progress is a
kind of false scientific confidence
based on previous confidence previous
results one can start an investigation
or an inquiry with a sort of a priori or
from the beginning certainty about how
it should or is going to work out right
this can be a real problem in fact
because it's so congruent with what
human minds have evolved to do which is
to assign agency to patterns and and and
thereby learn about mechanisms in the
world however as a scientist it's
important to remain open-minded there
are some structures in how we think
about science that allows us to to catch
ourselves if you will and make sure that
we're not making a mistake one of them
is to always have a null hypothesis or
some a simultaneous model or explanation
of the data at hand which posits that
nothing special is happening right and
so before we can conclude that our
favorite nifty idea is actually
occurring we have to be able to reject
the idea that nothing special is going
on right an example of null hypotheses
include
things like that cigarettes don't cause
cancer right in order to confirm that
cigarettes cause cancer we need to
reject the null hypothesis that they
don't and and so that's part of the the
structure of science now lots of people
think of the null hypothesis as simple
or simpler but in fact if cigarettes
don't cause lung cancer then all those
cases of lung cancer are individually
different and complicated so the null
hypothesis can actually be more
complicated explanation then the then
the then the main hypothesis right or
the the the the the signal hypothesis so
in science especially in evolutionary
science we have found that it's really
important to overcome our rational
desire to see meaning and direction in
every data set and ask the question do
we know if anything special is really
happening
[Music]
you